hello everyone welcome to today how's it
going Jen oh my goodness I'm just so
stressed out we are shopping because we
were heading off to tomorrow
I didn't tell so we're heading off to
they having a sale friends and family
but not enemies it's like I've got the
same vlog for the past couple of days I
end up coming here and I don't even find
anything that I want I hate shopping the
drinks that I don't like shopping with
auditors and then I never know where to
put this
please coming in tonight will you send
me a clip of Brie and you pick her up at
the airport I think is a love really
stupid maybe we get her something nice
yeah I'd rather get her something nice
even though it's really funny it's a
real brie shirt that's a blue shirt
there's something really really cute I'm
Agatha meter pets most location up in a
run for it oh no sorry
who looks good you got to take them
buddy
I know I need to get some bikinis your
had a lot cuz I looked your couple weeks
ago and they're all gone
and now woman Sam
you're one of those no dancing wing huh
look at this he's gonna be so perfect
for the world I get the black moon and
I'm doing it right or does it no well
all your stuff for fall oh no all my
stuff back so I found a bunch of things
make sense
none of them are bathing suits and
that's the main thing that I needed
I found sweatpants only sweatpants where
we're going
gonna have to go through everything that
I have at home and just hope I have a
couple I know I have some I'm just not
sure if I really like a bit of them you
want to Lululemon they always make me
happy
they always got a great stuff I'm
obsessed with this I got a few great
items at Lululemon I got the same Gans
well we might have but I also a little
bit up happens I cannot find a single
bathing suit
don't do that he told me you know why I
don't believe it at the airport the
airport bathing's is in the airport like
that when you get to the destination
gonna be like Ohio would you forget
Aloha for that side I'll tell my folks
are here how many of you know goodbye
sweet home are you gonna go to camp by
jenna in the back seat were taken into
camp everybody say bye to Mandy I miss
you so much I'm just trying last thing I
want to do right now is drink a Gharib
amante but I haven't packed a single bit
and we're leaving 6:00 a.m. we leaving
the house it's exam
[Music]
well done
officialy 10:38 i haven't finished
packing all of my electronics I got my
clothes done but the thing that takes
the longest is my electronics because I
got to make sure I have everything you
have extra hard drives I'm taking four
GoPros because I plan on shooting a
little comparison video while I'm there
breanne officially has landed in Los
Angeles what free this is for Justine I
have to send her chocolate she would you
missed the cute though oh my gosh we
just like you jug lady just like Maddie
this is Brees luggage here's Bruce
here's my part I have no idea
although tomorrow's video starts the
first day of my week of Halloween videos
so stay tuned for those they're fun
cooking videos and I have nothing else
to say so I'll see you later bye
[Music]
we haven't figured it out we're here for
meat belong previous to this it looks so
bad it honestly looked like I was going
on a potato like people say it looks
like you film that on a potato it's
actually did look like I built it on the
GoPro Hero 5 but apparently indoor shots
never look so good on a GoPro it looks
nothing like 1970 like us shopping
yesterday it looks disgusting weapon are
shot and Lavagirl spill into the GoPro
we're waiting for Bree Bree Bree Bree
where's Bree there she is
eNOS lahpet to the games I lost my
dongle
so my needs new tooth headphone crap one
what those girls glow - we did this
waterproof why are they armed
I got I got to get my bag I left it on
the tender through TV on the Best Buy
are you yes I wanted to go to Best Buy
yesterday but it closed
[Music]
can't wait to open this I've also got
Joey's book to read I love this cover
these are like my favorite colors
together you know I got a surprise three
with what I look like
oh it is real yeah I'm just um
shadow yeah the prescription yes I'll
get you another prescription suppose
look actually really nice oh my god I
can throw up I'm not really here
telegrapher Toby look like look you guys
is a babe you I don't know what it is
but it's really oh my god yeah my eyes
are like diamonds
[Music]
do you guys see what the first thing is
that we spotted you in Hawaii
Starbucks baby
we're picking up our luggage and we're
going to go check in and
you think we should get a Starbucks we
think about a refresher very very
viscous I think I might want to chili
mocha frappuccino thank you low chili
hit chili mocha new chili spicy but is
it also chilled yes I might get a coffee
Frappuccino light here's our third drink
breeze getting a hot drink oh look at
this
look at all this stuff wow that's a lot
of stuff
[Music]
you
we made it I am flying my drone right
out this door I'm gonna fly so fast
right off the bed I'll hear
oh my degree wait I'll hold on
here she is here oh it's Justine you're
gonna have special guests maybe how do I
get out of here
breathe this place is so pretty
it's amazing I want to say it's
beautiful real I'm definitely gonna make
aa nice Hawaiian dish here beautiful
dining room
Janna word hello me too
look at this this is the master bedroom
right kids oh goodness I just ran into
this plant I can't make so much for
watching I will see you in some future
videos cuz I've got nothing else for you
I'm tired I'm gonna relax and edit and
see you soon
[Music]
that's right
you
[Music]